sits on his mother's grave
as it's being prepared he's not yet
ready to say goodbye
his story of mourning is one of
thousands around the country
every day as india's streets empty
because of localized lockdowns
burial grounds and crematoriums continue
to work
day and night and in india's poorest
states uttar pradesh and bihar
100 bodies of suspected coven 19 victims
have been found
floating in the ganges river
our officials are at the scene and
investigating we are trying to find out
where did these dead bodies come from
how did they get here
and their numbers with crematoriums
around the country
struggling to deal with a huge increase
in bodies residents of gazipur in uttar
pradesh say they informed the local
administration about a shortage of wood
for cremations
we told the administration that the dead
are being thrown in the water because of
a shortage of wood
bodies from around 12 or 13 villages
have been thrown in the water
bihar's government denies reports of
wood shortages it says it's carrying out
post-mortems on the bodies to determine
the causes of death
elsewhere in india patients are
continuing to die because of oxygen
shortages
26 in the southern state of goa
yesterday we had a requirement of 1200
cylinders
we got only 400 there was interrupted
oxygen supply from 2am to 6am
which caused a lot of deaths
cases are increasing in southern india
where 18 people also
died from oxygen shortages this week in
the states of andhra pradesh
and telangana despite the number of
cases dropping in about half of india
states including the worst affected
regions of maharashtra and delhi
one in five people testing for covert 19
gets a positive result
and that's because the virus has simply
spread to other areas most notably
the five states where regional elections
were held in april
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi